in a fractious and unruly chamber one
parliamentarian's personal story managed
to unite the parties that
was jamie wallace a conservative who as
well as speaking out about being a
victim of rape and blackmail has
announced that he is trans the first uk
mp to do so
even before pmq's colleagues
congratulated him with handshakes and
saps on the back later party leaders
added their
that the praise stands
with you and will give you the support
that you need to leave to live freely as
yourself can i start by joining the
prime minister and his remarks in
relation to the honourable member for
bridge end it's good to see the member
for bridgend in the chamber this
afternoon i commend him for his
statement earlier today
that was a changing approach at least
from boris johnson who made a joke about
gender at a dinner for conservative mps
last night today sakia stamina
resurrected one of his party's favorite
topics with four questions on the cost
of living crisis and government tax
rises
does the prime minister still think
that he and the chancellor are tax
cutting conservatives 15 tax rises the
highest tax burden for 70 years how did
he find a chancellor as utterly cynical
as he is
when i spoke to sakir this week he
seemed pretty surprised at how badly
rishi sunak's spring statement had gone
down with some right-wing newspapers and
the labour team believe that timing is
potentially now on their side because
the political agenda is less dominated
by the war in ukraine tomorrow the party
is due to
launch their campaign for the local
elections with a big focus on the cost
of living and then on friday
we have the energy price cap rising by
over 50 percent if we analyze the labour
leaders language today uh one word tax
appears more than any other a total of
uh 12 times as well as working people
boris johnson hit back with attacks on
the labour leaders consistency
even by the standards of captain
hindsight mr speaker if we listen to
captain heinz
we would not have come out of we would
not have come out of lockdown in july
last year mr speaker we do at least
expect some consistency from uh this
this human weather vein
but there was one claim from the prime
minister on taxes which was greeted with
incredulity by some opposition mps they
want to raise taxes we want to cut taxes
and that's what we're doing and mr
speaker our analysis of boris johnson's
language today shows him using pretty
similar words to kyostama taxes and tax
feature as well as the economy and a
chancellor there was also a brief
interchange on partygate after the met
announced those 20 fines were being
issued
either he's trashing the ministerial
code
or he's claiming he was repeatedly lied
to by his own advisors but he didn't
know what was going on in his own house
in his own office
it was it was only a week or so ago
where he was saying that i shouldn't
resign of course the of course the the
the
investigators must must get on with
their job meanwhile the pm was
questioned on the uk's issuing of visas
for ukrainian refugees from the lib dems
when wealthy businessmen
from over 50 countries can come to the
uk visa free
why does the prime minister insist
that a traumatized ukrainian mother and
child
must first fill out a visa form
and even one senior tory of 28 300
applications
submitted under the sponsorship scheme
by people displaced in putin's war
just 2
700. have been processed
parliament wraps up for the easter break
tomorrow and the fact that conservative
mps will no longer be in westminster for
the next two and a half weeks will be a
relief for boris johnson i'm sure his
next challenge is the local elections on
may 5th